Taylor Swift an NFL plant so we all know
that the NFL has taking some heat due to
domestic violence in CTE and according
to my source Rick after an emergency
meeting the NFL suits claimed that they
quote needed the Swifty support and
Taylor Swift has proven to be the only
thing that's Recession Proof given her
erors to her domination she's huge so
that she and Travis are like full-on
dating what does the Taylor Swift affect
Ben well she's boosted ticket sales
jersey sales and everyone's stoked on
ketchup I mean that's a trifecta on top
of that Travis Kel's Jersey has gone up
400% and she's doubled viewers on the
games now I'm not saying that Taylor
Swift is getting paid to date Travis
Kelce I'm saying that she should be and
the latest update is that Travis was spy
doing the Walk of Shame from her
apartment so we ask here at CNN were
they playing chess or were they